all right people settle in relax  give me a call  this is on the line  are you ready I'm always ready we're  expecting your calls talk to Elvis live  on air and tell him about all of your  issues and problems  it is radio hosted  okay we got Gary on the line what say  you Gary  foreign  belong to someone you know no it belongs  to somebody not very nice  and I'm  picking out his whole family  [Music]  Gary what was that I'm breaking into the  top hey Gary stop wait come on why I  hurt his family I mean they're innocent  you're better than that Gary tell me  calmly  where exactly are you  your house  worst night of your life  see I created a game and I think you're  gonna love it  [Music]  this can still end well  I wanted to end well  I don't want to die here  I wonder if we don't want to die we  gotta fight  [Music]  so how about you tell us the truth we're  all listening show yourself your  slippery son of a